So on Monday, on the day of the total solar eclipse,
my best friend, Tom Sweeney,
here he is. As I was picking him up from the jail,
he was arrested,
obviously, and, um,
he's currently being charged with a Class B misdemeanor,
disorderly conduct.
Why was he arrested for disorderly conduct?
Allegedly, he was disrupting a university event by using a megaphone
as part of a pro Palestine protest that we were holding on Indiana
University's campus in Bloomington, Indiana.
We were doing nothing illegal,
Sweeney said. In fact,
we were doing something
that most people in the crowd were very grateful
was being done.
This is true. Um,
we were shown a lot of support.
Indiana University really showed out for us.
Number one, I should have the charges dropped regardless, without a fee,
without hours,
because there was no crime committed,
Sweeney said. Second,
the ability to have me with this charge lingering for so many months
is a tactic to disincentivize me from participating
in any future speech activities
that may be disappointing to the university.
This, to me,
is why he was arrested in the first place.
I believe that
the Indiana University
Police Department simply wanted to make a statement.
The university didn't wanna have their precious solar eclipse event
being eclipsed by our pro Palestine protest,
and they want to dissuade future protesters from participating.
There's also this claim that Sweeney was interrupting a live concert
at Done Meadow
by speaking into a Megaphone
and was asked several times to stop before being arrested.
This is simply not true.
I was there myself to witness that
he was not warned or asked to stop before being arrested.
We were also in the opposite corner of Done Meadow
from where this concert was taking place.
Um, the concert was taking place,
if you're familiar with Bloomington,
in the corner near Kirkwood and Indiana Avenue.
We were in the direct opposite corner,
and we intentionally went there because it was quieter.
Considering that Sweeney's only alleged crime is using a megaphone,
I think any reasonable prosecutor is going to drop these charges.
Frankly, it's embarrassing that IUPD even arrested him
to try and make a statement and dissuade protesters from protesting.
Because we're going to continue to resist.
The university
is going to continue to see protest from students and alumni.
If anything, this arrest is only strengthened our cause
and strengthened our solidarity.